[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde France Allemagne pourquoi ça
tangue France - Allemagne un couple un
tandem une relation au cœur de l'Europe
un trait d'union fondateur le pouvoir de
durer de l'Europe politique il fallait
bien cela après trois effroyables
conflits la guerre 1870
la Première Guerre mondiale la Seconde
Guerre mondiale ont mis aux prises ces
deux nations mais qui vont se retrouver
pour bâtir deux concerts une Europe de
la paix de la coopération et de la
prospérité contrairement aux légendes
sur une alliance quasi naturelle et
harmonieuse entre nos deux pays il y a
toujours eu entre eux et des bas une
émulation politique respective à base de
frictions conjoncturelles et
structurelle sur l'économie les
institutions la stratégie vis-à-vis des
États-Unis de la Russie de la Chine de
l'OTAN pourquoi s'en étonner car comme
les noces le philosophe Pierre Manon nos
nations diffèrent par leur histoire
politique cette distinction historique
n'aura pas empêché de faire de l'Europe
une communauté intégrée de peuples et de
nations une puissance commerciale et
même militaire une union territoriale et
politique que nous envies les Amériques
et l'Asie à l'aube de ce troisième
millénaire marqué par des crises
économiques et financières et des
conflits guerriers notamment la guerre
en Ukraine et sans oublier la pandémie
covid-19 et bien que la coopération
franco-allemande fonctionne nous
assistons à un essoufflement de la
relation franco-allemande pourquoi et
dans quel domaine c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec mes invités que je vous
présente Hans Zitter Lucas vous êtes
ambassadeur de la République fédérale
d'Allemagne en France Pierre Lelouch
vous êtes ancien ministre chargé des
affaires européennes et expert
international Edouard Guillot vous êtes
amiral et ancien séma pardonnez-moi chef
d'état-major des armées Maurice Gourdeau
montagne vous êtes ambassadeur vous
l'avez été notamment dans de nombreux
pays européens et anciens secrétaire
général du Quai d'Orsay
[Musique]
alors malgré une activité diplomatique
chargée ces derniers temps nous l'avons
vu avec la célébration du traité de
l'Elysée et plus récemment avec une
rencontre coordonnée avec le président
zélinski à laquelle assisté à Paris
monsieur Olaf Scholtz et à l'épreuve des
conflits l'axe franco-allemand
fonctionne il n'est pas rompu mais il ne
régente plus l'Union européenne il a
perdu de son élan politique et on dirait
même de sa force émotionnelle à votre
avis pourquoi Monsieur Lucas je ne
partage pas cette
cette vue là cette perspective donc j'ai
l'impression que la relation
franco-amande est basée sur un socle
très solide et particulièrement les
le dernier conseil ministre franco-amant
les célébrations à l'occasion du sois
son anniversaire du trait de Lézé ont
démontré qu'il y a une religion partagée
de l'Europe c'est à dire la nécessité
vraiment de de bâtir de construire une
Europe qui est plus souveraine dans un
contexte global extrêmement difficile
sur le plan politique avec des réformes
institutionnelles sur le plan technique
et économique c'est-à-dire renforcer
aussi la
l'indépendance souvretée économique de
l'Union européenne et troisièmement
aussi en ce qui concerne la nécessité
vraiment de construire une Europe de la
défense donc il rentrait à ma rentrée
dans le détail un bon nombre de projets
très concrets du front commun au service
de l'Europe pierre Lelouch vous partagez
cette analyse tout va bien entre France
- Allemagne non je crois que
c'est pas que tout va mal je pense les
liens j'ai demandé si tout va bien
extrêmement
important pour la suite des opérations
en Europe mais je crois que
la relation franco-allemande a été
affectée très profondément
bien avant la guerre en Ukraine par le
le changement dans la corrélation des
forces entre nos deux pays l'Allemagne
unifiée c'est puissamment de morale a
été unifiée ce qui était un énorme
changement par rapport à la période
précédente j'avais beaucoup écrit à
l'époque là-dessus il y a 30 ans
mais surtout elle s'est renforcée de
façon
économique de façon considérable alors
que nous nous affaiblissions il y a un
différentiel qui moi me préoccuper il y
a 10 ans quand j'étais au commerce
extérieur je voyais le déficit plongé
aujourd'hui il atteint 160 milliards
d'euros quand l'Allemagne avant les
histoires de gaz était à plus de 100
milliards donc on avait un delta de
quelque chose comme 300 milliards
d'euros entre la France et
l'Allemagne c'est-à-dire 15 points de
PIB
considérable donc une puissance
industrielle en Allemagne très
importante alors que nous affaiblissions
et puis je dirais aussi le fait que avec
l'élargissement de l'Europe
est plus encore après la guerre ou avec
la guerre en Ukraine l'Allemagne a
retrouvé son rôle de pivot au centre de
l'Europe et nous nous avons été quelques
peu marginalisés à la périphérie
d'ailleurs Sigma Gabriel l'ancien
ministre allemand il a fait étrangères
l'a dit publ et je partage tout à fait
cet avis donc il y a eu un espèce de
déport de la France l'Allemagne retrouve
en son rôle pivot entouré par toute leur
centrale et son influence son poids
économique
et donc ça ça crée des tensions ce qui
donne aussi à l'Allemagne la possibilité
de d'affirmer de plus en plus une
autonomie dans ses décisions que nous
avons subi dans beaucoup de cas que ça
existe de finances d'énergie on va
rentrer dans le détail on va rentrer
dans un tout dernier point
ce qui aujourd'hui caractérise encore
plus cette relation franco-allemande qui
est encore une fois très important
c'est le fait que avec l'Ukraine le
centre de gravité de l'Europe c'est
complètement basculé vers la Pologne et
les Baltes et les Scandinaves
et marginaliser pas seulement la France
mais la France et l'Allemagne ensemble
dont la dans le rôle pilote de cet
ensemble que nous avons créé ensemble et
maintenant j'allais dire presque
secondaire ce qui fait que avec le rôle
de la Pologne et des baltes on voit
arriver à nouveau membre dans l'Union
européenne qui s'appelle les États-Unis
d'Amérique
on va on va rester sur la première
question avec Maurice Gourdon montagne
écoutez les commentaires sont nombreux
en France et en Allemagne qui disent que
l'Allemagne s'éloigne de la voie
communautaire
vous le pensez Maurice Gourdon montagne
je ne crois pas je crois que les ce qui
a été dit précédemment et par Pierre
Lelouch et par l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne
me paraît extrêmement juste il y a une
dissymétrie entre la France et
l'Allemagne qui s'est accentué avec le
temps et donc il y a un besoin permanent
de se réadapter de recomposer ensemble
et c'est une dynamique permanente qui
nécessite un effort politique ce n'est
pas la la première fois que la relation
franco-allemande subit des chocs là
c'est un choc majeur c'est la guerre en
Ukraine qui change qui bouleverse les
centres de gravité qui bouleverse les
modèles économiques et peut-être les
modèles politiques franco-allemand donc
c'est à nous de réfléchir de rebondir
là-dessus nous avons des institutions
très solides qui encadre la relation
franco-allemande et qui nous permet de
nous parler constamment et nous sommes
très différents les Allemands vous
l'avez dit en introduction ne sont pas
les Français Pierre Manon le dit nous
sommes extrêmement différents un de mes
premiers patrons m'avait dit vous savez
les Allemands ne sont pas des Français
qui parlent allemand bah oui c'est la
vérité et donc la relation
franco-allemande quand j'étais
ambassadeur à Berlin je l'appelais un
combat de chaque jour parce que les
Allemands sont là nous sommes ici et
donc il faut chercher à se rapprocher
quand la volonté politique est là on
trouve quelque chose encore faut-il être
dans un rapport de force sous la France
a les moyens d'affirmer qui elle est et
nous avons faibli dans un certain mesure
mais néanmoins la politique c'est l'art
précisément de surmonter ces
contradictions oui votre avis et toi
je serai non pas un peu plus nuancée
mais me plaçant sur un sous un angle un
peu plus militaire
nous sommes partis dans les années
70-80 d'une dissymétrie assumée parce
que nous étions déjà membres du Conseil
de sécurité m'ont permanence avec droit
de veto parce que nous avions un outil
militaire alors que l'Allemagne avait
comme disait
l'inspecteur général de la Bundes verts
au début des années 2000 son armée
s'était des citoyens en uniforme
et ils sont des élèves parce que c'était
le début des affaires en Afghanistan et
cette dissymétrie a disparu où est en
train petit à petit de disparaître alors
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
moments qui
l'ont marqué la chute du mur de Berlin
et je vais faire du bail j'y étais ce
soir là donc c'était quand même assez
extraordinaire et puis ensuite il y a eu
les interventions y compris par
l'Allemagne sur le théâtre ex yougoslave
puis
l'envoi de troupes à l'extérieur de
l'Europe par la bundeswers ça c'est
l'Afghanistan et après trois ans veuve
clandestin est un an me disait ça y est
j'ai enfin des soldats alors que les
modalités d'utilisation des forces
allemandes n'étaient pas du tout les
mêmes et Pierre Lelouch s'en souvient
puisque nous y étions ensemble à une
époque que celle de des forces
françaises ou des autres forces
européennes et puis maintenant
effectivement on a continué avec les
affaires africaines et maintenant la
guerre en Ukraine
change encore la donne donc si nous si
nous partons d'un état 0 par rapport à
il y a 30 ans oui il y a une décimétrie
qui est apparue mais à mon avis en
réalité ça rééquilibre
l'Allemagne retrouve au-delà une place
normale au-delà de votre unanimité
là-dessus
en 70 ans de construction européenne il
y a eu de très grandes choses qui ont
été faites la Secale en communauté
économique du charbon et de l'acier le
marché commun l'euro Maastricht etc ce
que vous pourriez citer une grande
réalisation au cours de ces deux
dernières décennies où est la à la fois
en termes d'approfondissement politique
et d'élargissement politique qui a été
bloqué au sud avec la Turquie et à l'est
aujourd'hui avec la guerre non je peux
vous donner un exemple parce que je l'ai
vécu c'était pendant la crise 2008 alors
avec beaucoup de mal
Nicolas Sarkozy a eu beaucoup de mal à
convaincre de la Merkel qu'il fallait
sauver la Grèce et en même temps l'Union
européenne et l'euro
contre toutes les réserves possibles du
côté allemand banque centrale mon
homologue à l'époque il y avait des
règles on les appliquait
on est arrivé au forceps on est arrivé
on a réussi à convaincre l'Allemagne de
mutualiser on a mis une normande
d'argent on a mis beaucoup de centaines
de milliards d'euros pour sauver
l'Allemagne et l'euro on l'a fait et ça
c'était contraire à toutes les règles
allemandes sur la bonne gestion de la
monnaie donc ça on l'a fait après il y a
des choses qui vont moins bien
honnêtement aujourd'hui
l'amiral parlait de de la montée en
puissance de l'Allemagne en matière de
défense et elle est nécessaire pour la
défense européenne vous verrez on
abordera dans le détail mais bon
franchement si je regarde le catalogue
des programmes en commun je suis un peu
dévasté parce que beaucoup de choses
qu'on devait faire ensemble ne sont pas
faites en raison de la position
allemande il s'agisse du char
l'hélicoptère etc patrouille aérienne
surveillance maritime etc c'est pas bon
on a une divergence y compris sur la
défense anti-aérienne il reste plus que
le projet d'avion de combat futur mais
c'est pas bon on va en parler dans le
détail Maurice bourdon montagne je
voudrais avoir un avis
votre avis personnel le traité de Nice
a voulu un certain approfondissement des
relations il a été suivi après il y a eu
le traité de Lisbonne etc mais est-ce
que il y a pas eu à ce niveau là une
dissension qui a entraîné une fêlure
dans la mesure où la représentativité de
l'Allemagne a été augmentée et je me
souviens en tant que journaliste que
Helmut Schmidt n'était pas favorable à
cette chose là
je crois que il pardonnez-moi vous avez
raison vous avez raison de rappeler ces
souvenirs du traité de Nice qui s'est
soldé somme toute par un échec puisqu'il
a fallu très vite passer à autre chose
et qu'on a eu la Convention européenne
organisée sous la présidence de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing à l'époque qui aboutit
à des jouets qui est le même à n'a pas
abouti et qui néanmoins a permis
d'aboutir néanmoins à ce qui est devenu
plus tard le traité de Lisbonne donc une
réorganisation des équilibres au sein de
l'Union européenne c'était indispensable
on ne pouvait pas faire continuer à
faire semblant de dire que l'Allemagne
pesait moins lourd dans dans l'Union
européenne lorsqu'il s'agissait de
prendre des décisions qu'un certain
nombre d'autres pays je remarque
néanmoins que des dispositifs ont été
créés avec des majorités qualifiées pour
servir de blocage au cas où il y a eu
des décisions qui ne correspondaient pas
je dirais à la tendance qui devait se
dégager durée dans un consensus donc
c'est une c'est un système qui n'est pas
parfait qui trouve son équilibre mais on
ne peut pas nier la réalité la question
aujourd'hui et c'est le cas d'ailleurs
dans les relations internationales il y
a les réalités les réalités il faut les
prendre en compte quand un pays pèse
plus lourd ça doit être pris en compte
après ça on s'organise et c'est
précisément le rôle de la France et de
l'Allemagne dans ce tandem c'est le mot
que je préfère le tandem et d'ailleurs
très souvent quand j'étais en Allemagne
je citais je citais ce qui est un tandem
dans les pays du Maghreb notamment où on
dit un atelage attendait un attelage peu
importe s'il y a un chameau et un âne
c'est de tirer dans la même direction
alors je sais pas qui est dans le rôle
de qui dans cette affaire mais dans tous
les cas la France et l'Allemagne sont un
attelage qui pour l'Europe tire dans une
direction commune c'est ce que nous
faisons il y a une chose
vous regrettez ou pas ce qui s'est passé
entre le regrette rien de ce qui s'est
passé parce que je pense que les
équilibres politiques du moment nous ont
permis d'aboutir ensemble un résultat
qui a créé une dynamique après ça il
faut s'adapter il y a un élargissement
potentiel de l'Europe qu'il faut
regarder ensemble il y a des équilibres
pierre Lelou je disais des centres de
gravité qui se déplacent il faut les
prendre en compte mais je crois qu'il
n'y a rien à regretter ce qui est
important aussi vous aussi demandé un
exemple bon je pourrais citer Airbus qui
est quand même
majeur on va rentrer dans les le
commerce franco-allemand c'est quand
même les principaux échanges en Europe
se font entre la France et l'Allemagne
les principaux investissements étrangers
on va parler de ça dans le détail si
vous voulez mais je voudrais laisser une
histoire de réussite monsieur vous
l'avez un mot à dire à propos du traité
de Nice bon je partage tout à fait ce
qui a été dit par Moscou de montagne
mais je voulais revenir sur ce que sur
votre question donc est-ce qu'il y a des
projets récents donc je mentionnais dans
ce contexte mon de cette initiative
franco-amande pour le prendre relance
c'était vraiment en pas majeur n'est-ce
pas ce programme de 750 milliards
d'euros et c'était de la part de
l'Allemagne et c'était une grande
conscience de la mutualisation partielle
des dettes ça ça c'est vraiment
important pour la suite 2008 on va
c'était il y a trois ans et aussi encore
une fois donc si si vous analysez le
discours de de pract du champs les
choses ce que le président de la
République a dit dans un discours à la
Sorbonne il y a beaucoup de points
communs beaucoup de points communs
[Musique]
nous venons de voir la pensée profonde
de deux grands écrivains Victor Hugo et
got ils auraient pu se rencontrer par
exemple à Weimar ce qui montre pourquoi
j'ai pris ces deux écrivains c'est pour
montrer que les relations
littéraires des relations les relations
entre hommes entre femmes etc peuvent
avoir une importance considérable alors
la relation franco-allemande elle est
identifiée à juste titre à des couples
qui partagent et qui partagent une
connivence forte de Gaulle et Adenauer
avait une même analyse politique
on célèbre le 60e anniversaire du traité
de l'Élysée c'est leur œuvre Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing et Helmut Schmidt
avait une commune analyse économique
Mitterrand et Cole
se retrouver sur le terrain historique
puis la diplomatie l'a emporter sur
l'imagination sur la grandeur politique
une certaine indifférence a suivi et des
bifurcations que l'on va analyser dans
le détail mais qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ce qu'il n'y a plus si je peux dire
cette espèce de relation élective qu'il
y a eu à travers les grands couples de
l'histoire franco-allemande Maurice
Gourdon montagne il y a eu des grands
couples il y en a que vous n'avez pas
cité qui sont Chirac et Schröder qui ont
été d'accord ensemble pour refuser la
guerre en Irak ce qui n'était pas rien
résisté je dirais à la pression d'une
mise sur des peuples sur des
gouvernements pour les faire entrer dans
une guerre qui n'avait aucune raison
d'être qui était une guerre d'agression
donc c'était quand même quelque chose
qui nous a permis de beaucoup avancer à
l'époque mais je remonterai plus loin
Émile je crois qu'il y a une affinité
entre la France et l'Allemagne sur des
valeurs
que ces valeurs nous avons partagées
pendant les lumières et pendant ce qu'on
les Allemands appelle la housse clairo
mais que ce sont des mouvements un peu
différents des valeurs de liberté des
valeurs de conquête je dirais de pour
les peuples et jusqu'en 1848 nous avons
échangé et nous avons marché ensemble
c'est le nationalisme qui nous a fait
diverser et aboutir à ses guerres que
vous avez citées et puis en 1945 non
seulement on ne voulait plus faire de
guerre mais on s'est rendu compte que
nous avions ce socle commun de valeurs
partagées de et notamment autour du
concept de liberté je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très profond entre les
Français et les Allemands que nous
devrions essayer de redécouvrir parce
que c'est nous vivons dans un monde dont
on dit qu'il est liberticide par
certains aspects la France et
l'Allemagne sont en avant s'agissant des
combats pour la liberté
sur les couples si on peut utiliser ce
terme moi ce que je crois c'est que si
on monte
ça a raison de passer à l'histoire mais
l'un des paradoxes de l'histoire des
deux derniers siècles c'est que nous
Français nous avons inventé le
nationalisme allemand c'est la
révolution française et Napoléon qui a
fabriqué excusez-moi l'Allemagne de
Bismarck a été fabriqué en France c'est
tout à fait regrettable parce qu'on l'a
payé lourdement après mais on aimait
beaucoup l'Allemagne quand elle était
éparpillée en toute sorte de petites
bûcher avec lesquels on s'allier quand
on c'est nous qui l'avons unifié ensuite
la réunification la réunifiée et la
question que je posais dans un de mes
livres il y a 30 ans c'est qu'est-ce qui
va se passer maintenant que l'Allemagne
est à nouveau uni est-ce qu'elle va
rester ancrée dans la famille européenne
elle a plus besoin de l'Europe s'en est
plus à anneau à Noël avait besoin de
l'Europe
pour exorciser le passé pour trouver une
nouvelle
respectabilité internationale
l'Allemagne d'aujourd'hui n'a plus
besoin de ça la guerre est très loin et
tout le monde a beaucoup des nouvelles
générations oublient tout ça donc que va
faire l'Allemagne surtout dans l'après
guerre du GRAINE c'est la question
stratégique de fond qui se pose dans la
pré guerre et dans le système de
sécurité en Europe est-ce qu'on va être
capable nous Français aujourd'hui
affaibli foutu dehors d'Afrique
foutu dehors par les Américains du
Pacifique alors nous avons la Calédonie
et les Tahiti la façon dont les
Américains et les anglaises sont
conduits dans le Pacifique est un vrai
semblable russe joue leur rôle en
Afrique mais nous on est affaibli là
dedans et donc la question de fond je
termine parce que c'est mes yeux une des
questions cruciales post-guerre
la Russie mais il y a aussi le rôle que
l'Allemagne jouera au centre de l'Europe
ou bien on est capable de maintenir ce
tandem ce mariage franco-allemand qui a
été à la source de la naissance de
l'Union européenne l'Union européenne
c'est la réconciliation franco-allemande
ou bien on est capable de cimenter ça
dans quelque chose qui va être très
différent avec des Polonais des baltes
des balkaniques ça va être ingérable
attention une Europe à 30-35 excusez-moi
mais ça va être très très compliqué donc
il faut vraiment que ce pilier
franco-allemand soit hyper fort s'il
n'est pas fort alors le risque c'est
qu'on bascule dans d'autres dans
d'autres formats et où l'Allemagne devra
se poser elle la question de ce qu'elle
veut être au milieu de l'Europe et c'est
un moment laissez-moi donner la parole
si vous permettez à 11h Lucas parce que
je voudrais qu'il y ait un équilibre
quand même de temps de parole et donc je
voudrais poser deux questions
on a évoqué
un sentiment en France sur l'Allemagne
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez
peut-être même en oubliant que vous êtes
ambassadeur mais à votre avis qu'est-ce
qu'on reproche
vue de Berlin à Paris et deuxièmement
est-ce que vous pensez pas que ce
souffle historique politique économique
qui a eu avec les différents domaines
n'est plus là aujourd'hui
en tout d'abord que je voudrais
et vous avez le droit d'avoir des
dissensions
un petit point sur ces questions donc où
va l'Allemagne
c'était toujours cette discussion en
France sur les instituts allemandes et
sur ce c'était une grande discussion
dans le contexte de la réunification
et là c'était notre réponse c'était
Maastricht c'était toujours Europe et à
mon avis ça peut changer donc si
on regarde par exemple le résultat des
derniers élections législatives en
Allemagne 85 % des Allemands ont voté
pour des parties européens pour qui donc
le front commun est tout à fait central
et à mon avis aussi si on regarde les
sondages donc les derniers sondages
nous disent que donc pour plus de 80%
des Allemands la France et le partenaire
le plus important le plus fiable donc il
y a là à mon avis en sentiment
comprends rien très fort au sein de la
population allemande au sein de la
classe politique qu'il n'aimait pas en
cause donc cette orientation classique
si vous voulez
de la manière envers l'Europe avec en
noyau dur franco-allemand et le
chancelier donc la répéter n'est-ce pas
dans son discours alors ça va il a dit
donc pour nous la France c'est une
notion indispensable indispensable je
pense que c'est un commentaire très fort
je suis
avec un certain intérêt je suis aussi
cette discussion sur la question est-ce
que l'Allemagne s'oriente vers l'Est
n'est-ce pas ça s'inscrit aussi dans une
certaine époque
mais sur ce point-là le centre de
gravité de l'Union européenne donc
économiquement donc c'est l'Allemagne
c'est la France c'est le Benelux Espagne
avec donc l'importance prenait
certainement là aussi donc d'une des de
nos partenaires à l'Est mais donc
vraiment donc un centre de gravité
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on dit ça mais il
y a quand même la réalité économique
alors permettez-moi de vous dire on dit
oui mais la relation franco-allemande il
y a eu Airbus Airbus Airbus bon mais
quand on regarde par exemple dans le
domaine de l'informatique
les relations de l'Allemagne avec la
Chine sont privilégiés si je ne me
trompe pas ou avait
alimenté la 5G allemande pour
60%. et si on prend l'industrie
automobile allemande elle est
extrêmement
développée en Chine et sa connexion
informatique vient quasi totalement de
Waver on a pensé c'est ce qu'on écrit
dans les journaux français et dans les
journaux allemands qu'il y avait là une
force pour l'Europe à travers le temps
d'un franco-allemand est-ce que vous
êtes pas pas gêné mais quand même
imaginons que demain il y ait une guerre
avec Taïwan comme nous avons la guerre
en Ukraine qu'est-ce que vous faites de
wave
oui il y a en ce qui concerne la Chine
et discussion en Allemagne et donc
depuis quelques temps disons que donc la
Chine donc ça reste en partenaire très
important
aussi très important pour toutes ces
questions dans le contexte du changement
climatique mais de l'autre côté il y a
dans ces dans nos relations l'Europe aux
États-Unis avec la Chine des éléments de
de compétition même de rivalité
systémique d'où la nécessité vraiment de
aussi de repenser un peu notre politique
vis-à-vis de la Chine c'est ce qu'on
fait donc
et donc la Chine donc a changé donc il
nous faut changer aussi notre politique
c'est-à-dire une offre diversifier aussi
nos relations commerciales et c'est ce
qu'on fait
édouardine il était un Vietnam donc
c'est tout à fait pour nous une
nécessité vraiment de diversifier nos
relations commerciales Édouard Guillot
stratégiquement est-ce que c'est gênant
que wave domine le numérique en
Allemagne oui forcément mais je crois
que l'explication elle est assez simple
c'est que au moins jusqu'à ces derniers
temps l'Allemagne a pensé que le soft
power la puissance 12 donc la puissance
économique se suffisait à elle-même et
du coup quand on est dans cette optique
aller chez Huawei ou un autre n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance à l'inverse
Poutine lui pense que seul la le hard
power la puissance militaire sert à
quelque chose je pense que c'est tout
aussi différent et
opposition d'une certaine façon entre la
position classique française qui essaie
l'alliance du soft power et du hard
power qui fait une diplomatie qui fait
une analyse stratégique et la position
allemande qui est restée alors qui est
en train de changer à cause des
événements pas seulement en Chine mais
en Ukraine c'est là
la vraie non pas rupture mais le vrai
faussé qu'il a pu y avoir j'ai
l'impression qu'il est quand même en
train de se réduire mais quand vous
pensez le monde en termes de puissance
vous ne mettez pas tous vos œufs dans le
même panier nous Français comme les
Britanniques d'ailleurs nous avons
toujours pensé le monde en termes de
rapport de puissance et qu'elle est même
je me souviens qu'au sein du Quai
d'Orsay il y avait ceux qui appartenait
ce qu'on appelait la secte mais
dont vous êtes et
je pense qu'on appelle la secte non
ceux qui pensaient égale que le rapport
de puissance sont importants mais
d'autres disaient non c'est pas ça c'est
uniquement la culture ce qui n'est pas
le cas uniquement l'économie il y a un
tout et ça c'est cette différence
d'analyse sur le reste du monde une fois
que vous avez ces différences d'analyses
vous avez des différences de choix oui
mais c'est pas ça n'est pas qu'une
différence de choix si vous prenez la
politique énergétique de l'Europe elle
n'existe pas il y a une dissension très
forte sur la question du nucléaire il y
a eu des problèmes au niveau de la
taxonomie c'est-à-dire des
investissements verts on a on a eu du
mal à fixer un prix d'électricité
abordable et les ménages des deux pays
d'ailleurs trinque en payant très cher à
cause de la question du gaz
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas régler ces
deux questions majeures pour l'économie
des deux pays à savoir le numérique et
l'énergie en allant vers une politique
énergétique et numérique tous les deux
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que ce qui
s'était passé depuis 20 ans depuis la
réunification notamment c'est le fait
que l'Allemagne
c'est imposé comme le poids lourd le
pivot de la politique européenne la
mesure que nous nous déclinions de notre
côté qu'on était devenu et de plus en
plus de mal à contrebalancer cette
puissance et cette puissance elle s'est
manifestée dans les domaines que vous
venez de dire et qui sont primordieux
celles qui a dictée
l'accord commercial entre l'UE et la
Chine c'est un Gallame c'est elle qui
l'a voulu et l'accord a été paraphe tout
à fait à la fin de l'année
2020 alors même qu'il y avait beaucoup
de réserves côté français mais on n'a
pas pu l'empêcher et cet accueil était
basé sur l'idée que rappelait l'amiral
savoir que le soft power devait amener
un changement systémique de la Chine ce
qui était d'ailleurs la même idée quand
on a fait rentrer la Chine dans l'OMC et
en général c'est la même chose avec la
Russie et le temps d'ailleurs non mais
sur la Russie c'est autre chose mais
c'est parallèle mais donc voilà ça c'est
un aspect des choses qui fait que avec
la dépendance de l'industrie automobile
Allemagne allemande en Chine ont
l'almana tiré l'Union européenne vers
une vision assez irénique de ce qu'est
la Chine l'autre point majeur dans
lequel l'Allemagne a vraiment
été l'architecte à mon avis d'un
désastre énergétique européen c'est
quand l'Allemagne c'est littéralement
drogué au gaz russe bon marché et elle
l'a fait parce que c'était l'un des
piliers de son succès économique de
l'énergie pas chère et sûre croyez-elle
et rappelez-vous c'est très intéressant
le deuxième case Auduc Nord Stream 2 a
été décidé après l'annexion de la Crimée
pas avant après c'est dire que c'est pas
seulement Madame Merkel ou monsieur
Schroder toute la classe politique
allemande toute l'industrie allemande
elle fait le pari de ce mode énergétique
renforcé par la montée en puissance des
verres en Allemagne très anti en
nucléaire on ferme les centrales
nucléaires j'étais là avec Madame Merkel
quand elle nous a dit un soir après
juste après Fukushima François Fillon et
à moi j'arrête le nucléaire en France et
vous vous allez devoir fermer Fessenheim
mais j'ai dit Madame la chancelière on
est encore un État souverain mais on a
quand même quelques années plus tard
fermé ce night sous la pression de
l'Allemagne et donc c'est ce poids
majeur de l'Allemagne sur tout ce qui
dictent le commerce l'énergie et bien
sûr la monnaie aussi même si il y a eu
des évolutions et quelque chose auquel
nous n'avons pas su par notre propre
faiblesse résister
suffisamment on aurait d'ailleurs rendu
au service aux Allemands si on avait été
un peu plus puissant dans le tandem
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose et
qu'est-ce qui se passe après le
chancelier scholls dès le début de la
guerre a dit c'est un moment tournant
c'est le tournant de la politique
allemande on recommence tout mais vers
quoi et nous nous sommes toujours à la
recherche en France de ce que nous
allons devenir aussi donc c'est pour ça
que je j'en appelle vraiment je suis pas
un Européen Béa j'ai vu ce que c'est que
la table du Conseil européen je sais à
quel point ça peut être ingérable et
souvent très décevant mais je sais que
s'il y a pas un tandem franco-allemand
très fort
là nous risquons des choses très graves
à l'avenir dans dans ce poste
Ukraine qui risque de déliter tout ce
qui reste devant merci
vous répondez à ce que vient de dire
pierre Lelouch sur la divergence très
claire sur la question de la politique
énergétique
en ce qui concerne la politique
énergique donc on a déjà
tiré des luçons n'est-ce pas de cette
dépendance dans le récit c'est-à-dire
pas au cours de 24 février de l'année
dernière donc on est sorti complètement
du gaz russe du pétrole russe du chablon
russe
l'électricité reste très cher sans
provoquer donc une crise majeure en
matière d'énergie et maintenant on est
dans plein de ce processus de la
transition verte et pour nous la
direction est assez claire il faut bien
entendu trouver un accord sur sur la
question du marché de l'électricité
n'est-ce pas donc vos amis mentionné
cette question là mais ça a été dit
aussi discuté en prendre à l'occasion du
Conseil ministre franco-am on a dit donc
il faut travailler ensemble là-dessus et
je suis tout à fait d'accord ou dans
toutes les questions toutes les
questions là il nous faut trouver un
accord fondament
que en ce qui concerne la question de
nucléaire nous sommes très différents ça
fait partie de nos différences mais il
faut aussi apprendre de vivre avec ces
différences là et c'est possible à mon
amour Maurice gourde montagne bien sûr
moi on est très différent sur le plan de
l'énergie j'étais à Berlin à l'époque où
la chancelière Merkel a décidé après
Fukushima de sortie parce qu'il y avait
déjà une tendance lourde en Allemagne
qui était anti-nucléaire pour des
raisons sans doute historiques des
raisons profondes des raisons
existentielles de l'Allemagne ce ne sont
pas je pense qu'il faut être juges ce ne
sont pas les Allemands qui nous ont
forcés à décider de passer de 75% de
fabrication d'électricité de production
d'électricité à 50% et c'est pas eux qui
nous ont forcés en France qui nous ont
amenés à prendre ces décisions à voter
une loi de programmation énergétique qui
est toujours en vigueur ce n'est pas eux
qui nous ont fait fermer faceenheim qui
nous ont fait annoncer qu'on allait
fermer 14 centrales et qu'on allait
ensuite se lancer un peu plus tard dans
la crise sur un programme de un nouveau
programme du nucléaire
je pense qu'il faut être juste il est
vrai que là nous avons une dissension
majeure qui n'est pas réglée et un
interloca sa raison il faut qu'on arrive
à recréer très vite un système qui
permet de payer le juste prix de
l'électricité parce que ça touche les
peuples mais ça c'est les conséquences
de cette guerre en Ukraine qui nous
prend de plein fouet qui bouleverse le
modèle noir en parler vous allez voir en
parler mais alors
je voudrais
aborder avec vous une question
stratégique majeure le président Joe
Biden a fait voter cette fameuse loi qui
s'appelle ira
et qui est une flèche de réduction actes
des centaines de milliards d'euros tout
ça pour
booster doper
l'industrialisation verte des États-Unis
alors on a vu que le ministre français
des Finances accompagné
de son équival généralement sont allés à
Washington mais franchement on est là
devant une bataille commerciale
en bon français ça s'appelle la
préférence nationale et je le dis
volontairement sans aucune référence de
politique intérieure c'est très
précisément ce que font les États-Unis
aujourd'hui objectifs les États-Unis
profitent du conflit en Ukraine pour
vendre des armements du gaz pour vendre
du gaz naturel liquéfié dans le bilan
carbone et juste absolument épouvantable
je n'ose même pas comparer au nucléaire
et pour l'instant les États-Unis
stratégiquement parlant sont les
gagnants je dis pas qu'à terme c'est
vrai mais aujourd'hui les gagnants du
conflit mais sur cette ce Green Deal
d'un côté et cette concurrence
commerciale imposée par Biden est-ce que
Monsieur l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne en
disait locas
le moment n'est pas venu de mutualiser
la politique économique et financière de
l'Union européenne pour pouvoir résister
en termes de compétitivité avec les
États-Unis par exemple tout d'abord pas
un intérêt à entrer dans une guerre
commerciale avec les États-Unis et même
le fait que les États-Unis misent sur la
transition verte
c'est principalement à mon avis en bon
message pour le pour le climat n'est pas
pour la question du changement des
climatiques en ce qui concerne donc les
aspects industriels je pense il faut
faire deux choses donc essayer n'est-ce
pas de d'obtenir des amants dans des
exceptions finalement ils créent une
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
traités l'Europe comme comme le Mexique
et les Canada première chose la deuxième
aspect c'est la question rendre l'Europe
plus compétitive et ça c'est la question
des mesures qu'on peut prendre sur le
sur la question de la flexibilisation
des règles des états je pense que c'est
très important et la question des il
faut agir beaucoup plus vite la
Commission européenne doit décider
beaucoup plus vite en ce qui concerne
les grands projets européens et
finalement il faut aussi comme vous
l'avez dit n'est ce pas mobiliser des
ressources financières donc il y a là
dans les dans les fonds qui existent
déjà le plan de relance encore des
moyens considérables c'est des engie
c'est la vie c'est la banque
d'investissement européenne donc il n'y
a pas pour le moment on manque
d'investissement il faut aussi
identifier les bons il y a pas
nécessaire c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir
un fond Mutuel pour que
concurrencer ou de se mettre en position
de ne pas être dépassé par les
États-Unis ça a été proposé par la par
la Commission européenne la l'idée de
créer en fond souverain mais tout
d'abord donc si donc si
on se rend compte que dans le plan de
relance 80% des ressources n'ont pas été
dépensées donc il faut tout d'abord
profiter de ce qui est déjà là très bien
pierre Lelou c'est après on va passer
aux questions de défense donc essayez
d'être concis si vous voulez bien vous
êtes réconcis j'ai dans cette maison en
2016 ouvert le débat sur
l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines et l'Inst comment l'Amérique
utilise son droit pour casser la
concurrence là ils viennent de passer
une loi qui est ouvertement en
protectionniste et qui dit venez à moi
les petits enfants venez investir si
vous êtes si vous construisez ici vous
aurez accès au financement locaux c'est
en fait une forme de cannibalisme
industriel au moment même où nos
entreprises sont frappées par une
explosion du prix de l'énergie en Europe
le prix de l'énergie c'est 4 à 5 fois le
prix aux États-Unis donc la
réindustrialisation qui était lancée en
France avec beaucoup de mal d'ailleurs
l'industriellement très puissante sont
prises en tenailles entre l'augmentation
du gaz et le protectionnisme américain
il faut que nous soyons capables entre
Français et Allemand en tout cas ce que
je conseillerais si j'étais aux affaires
de répondre par la réciprocité parce que
les Américains qu'est-ce qu'ils m'ont
dit moi
elle a été votée circuler il n'y a rien
à voir il fallait vous plaindre avant
c'est ce que j'ai entendu donc quand le
maire et son collègue monsieur avec voit
à Washington ils sont entendus
a été votée vous pouvez entrer chez vous
donc la seule chose que peut faire
utile l'Europe outre les investissements
indispensables c'est de faire en sorte
que le jeu soit égal à savoir que nous
soyons capables de riposter par le même
type de dispositif si on fait pas ça on
sera balayé et ce sera du calibanisme
industriel donc c'est le moment et là
aussi assez grave et c'est très
important
vous entendez
là-dessus sur je trouve que je pense
qu'il est important que ce soit
précisément le ministre français des
Finances et son collègue également de
l'économie qui soit ensemble parce que
nous pesons à nous deux 47% de la zone
euro il faut quand même le rappeler nous
représentons quelque chose qui pèse
c'est mon expérience chinoise en
l'occurrence quand nous apparitions
entre Français et Allemand ensemble
notre voie était beaucoup plus lourde
l'Allemagne pèse par elle-même la France
pèse un peu moins sur le plan industriel
et plein économique la combinaison des
deux est quelque chose d'extrêmement
fort je pense que les Américains le
regardent aussi comme ça et puis bon
ensuite sur ce qu'il faut faire
évidemment il y a une certaine palette
est-ce qu'il faut se lancer dans une
guerre commerciale je ne crois pas
néanmoins la fermeté est quelque chose
qui sinon il ne respecte
de démontrer et les Français les
Allemands en tête avec le soutien des
partenaires européens
[Musique]
alors le moment est venu d'aborder les
questions de défense
une politique européenne de défense et
de sécurité commune c'est un projet dont
on entend parler matin midi et soir et
notamment avec la guerre en Ukraine mais
est-ce que à ce niveau
la coopération doit se faire entre la
famille intra-européenne
quelle part doit avoir l'OTAN est-ce
qu'on peut exclure les États-Unis et
là-dessus il y a manifestement des vues
différentes entre Paris et Berlin
il y a forcément un certain nombre de
vues lié à l'histoire à l'histoire
militaire mais aussi à l'histoire
politique nous sommes obligés de
constater que l'OTAN a ressuscité
grâce à l'agression russe sur l'Ukraine
parce que sinon le temps était
effectivement en état de mort cérébrale
et donc on ne peut pas éliminer le temps
par ailleurs pour avoir une politique de
défense et de sécurité commune la
première chose c'est d'avoir une analyse
stratégique une analle et une
compréhension de l'état du monde et des
menaces partagées et ça à part la
tentative de ravir Solana au milieu des
années 2000 depuis il y a eu des petites
mises à jour mais qui en réalité n'ont
pas vraiment fait avancer la la
réflexion il y a des rapprochements je
constate des rapprochements depuis une
quinzaine d'années et même même si je
remonte au milieu des années 80 parler à
des stratèges ou des stratégies
allemands de ce qui se passait en
Afrique en disant il faudrait peut-être
quand même qu'on fasse attention c'était
juste même perdu on vous disait mais
vous n'avez rien compris c'est de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée
aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout le cas
donc il y a eu non pas un rapprochement
des points de vue mais un partage une
prise de conscience partagée d'un
certain nombre d'enjeux le chemin n'est
pas encore terminé donc si on prend les
contraintes qui sont le temps
le fait que nous n'avons pas exactement
encore la même perception de l'état du
monde
le fait que aussi est-ce que est-ce que
l'Allemagne n'est pas plus réaliste
est en peut-être je l'espère en train de
changer mais étant partisan ou partisane
du du soft power j'estime que c'était
pas réaliste vu l'état du monde la Chine
les États-Unis la Russie nous le prouve
tous les jours y compris l'Inde
vis-à-vis de la Chine et pas seulement
vis-à-vis du Pakistan à un moment ce
sont des rapports de puissance et comme
disent les Britanniques et les
Américains
might makes la puissance fait le droit
et on le voit et donc tant que nous ne
serons pas d'accord nous aurons beaucoup
de mal à avancer on peut avoir des
petites coopérations ponctuelles on a
essayé mais ça te fait maintenant plus
de 15 ans qu'on n'a pas réussi à
déployer le bataillon franco-allemand
oui alors Maurice Gourdeau montagne on
arrive à la question on peut fiévreuse
la France et l'Allemagne soutiennent
l'effort de guerre en Ukraine
on a même vu des réunions communes entre
la scholls et manuellement Macron et le
président zenenski
la Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis
font pareil jusqu'où vous pensez que la
France doit soutenir cette guerre et
est-ce qu'elle peut aller jusqu'à une
défaite de la Russie si on traduit ça
simplement ça veut dire que les Russes
quittent ce qui ne leur appartient pas à
savoir le dos bas c'est peut-être la
Crimée
parce que c'est une il faut bien vous
avez très bien posé le problème la
question c'est de savoir
de faire en sorte que l'Ukraine ne perde
pas et que l'Ukraine soit dans une
position la plus forte possible le jour
il s'agira un jour de s'asseoir une
table de négociation pour le moment le
terrain militaire n'est pas fixé on est
dans l'escalade une escalade qui est
celle des Russes et une escalade qui est
celle du des Occidentaux de l'Ukraine
soutenant les Occidentaux
ce point culminant n'est pas atteint
pour le moment les États-Unis
soutiennent l'Ukraine je ne suis pas
certain que dans le long terme ou même
dans le moyen terme les États-Unis
soient toujours de ce côté car elle a
les États-Unis en d'autres priorités qui
sont la Chine d'un côté et l'économie
américaine elle-même et quand on regarde
les sondages aux États-Unis aujourd'hui
on voit très bien que l'Ukraine est
moins prioritaire qu'elle n'était pas du
tout oui mais les gens des représentés
même c'est important d'avoir en tête les
facteurs externes la Chambre des
Représentants aujourd'hui à la main le
budget et elle est républicaine on est
dans la phase où on va préparer les
élections présidentielles américaines
donc qu'est-ce qui va se passer nous
allons nous retrouver avec l'Ukraine à
gérer je pense qu'il est très important
d'envoyer des signaux de soutien à
l'Ukraine mais des lignes rouges que
nous ne dépasserons pas oui mais vous
parlez de Line rouge permettez-moi de
vous dire qu'à ce sur ce plateau nous
avons eu beaucoup de responsables
français y compris des de grands
écrivains qui étaient russophiles et
russophone par exemple madame Carrère
d'encaus dans une émission que j'ai
tournée ici même a déclaré que Poutine
ruinait la Russie ruiner le peuple russe
et quand c'est bon alors si c'est le cas
ne faisons pas des comparaisons
historiques dramatiques mais dans ce cas
là faut-il que la France et l'Allemagne
accepte une défaite de la Russie sur ce
terrain je voudrais avoir votre avis
monsieur Lucas et notre avis monsieur le
look moi je voudrais tout d'abord venir
tout ce qui a été dit en ce qui concerne
le réalisme allemand en ce qui concerne
les affaires stratégiques je pense que
vraiment on nous cette guerre cette
agression russe c'était en coup de
semences très sévère c'est la raison
pour laquelle le chancelier parler d'un
changement de dépôts n'est-ce pas
des conséquences très concrètes sur le
plan stratégique tout d'abord dans
l'augmentation massive notre budget de
défense et 100 milliards d'euros pour
faire en sorte que au futur nous nous
soyons capables de dépenser plus de 2%
du pied pour la défense donc c'est c'est
assez remarquable deuxième point donc
cette décision aussi historique n'est-ce
pas délivré un des armes lourdes à
l'Ukraine on n'a jamais livré des armes
un pays qui qui est en guerre et qui
n'est pas le membre de l'Union
européenne le temps donc à mon avis donc
ça démontre vraiment en changement de la
pensée stratégique de l'Allemagne y
compris en ce qui concerne la relation
entre l'économie et la géopolitique et
les chars aujourd'hui les avions demain
non c'est autre chose je voulais dire
autre chose je vous ai dit que je
pensais que le fossé se réduisait
toujours pensé c'était on peut le
miracle en allemand le miracle est
économique au monde de dire bon tout
d'abord donc l'économie là j'ai le
politique ce sont des secteurs séparés
et maintenant je pense pour nous c'était
de montre donc on peut pas séparer ces
deux secteur aussi concerne le soutien
militaire pour l'Ukraine donc on a pris
ces décisions n'est-ce pas délivrer des
des chars de combat léopard et notre
position très claire on va soutenir
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps qu'il faudra
jusqu'où jusqu'au donc jusqu'à ce
qu'elle récupère son territoire
je pense que ça c'est la demande de
partager
de l'Union européenne aussi les
États-Unis donc c'est la restauration de
l'intrigue de l'intérêt de territoriale
le président zeneski a dit en défendant
l'Ukraine vous défendez l'Europe vous
êtes d'accord avec ça on va terminer
là-dessus est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée là la Russie a mis en
cause l'ordre européen avec cette
agression contre l'Ukraine et dans ce
sens-là donc il fait en sorte que la
Russie ne gagne pas cette guerre qui mis
en cause l'ordre est très clair Édouard
Guillot là-dessus et chacun donnera son
point de vue là-dessus
l'Ukraine doit gagner cette guerre ou
pas je vais le dire d'une façon presque
jésuite nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre nous Européens que l'Ukraine
perde
je pense mais ne pas perdre ça ne veut
pas dire gagner c'est encore c'est
encore autre chose mais vous êtes
militaire vous avez été le grand patron
de l'armée on gagne on perd une guerre
et bon et non non non malheureusement
c'est d'abord le militaire s'exprime le
militaire c'est on peut stabiliser un
front une option et que avec un
territoire libéré ou avec un territoire
partagé penser à
au problème Palestiniens qui dure depuis
1947 sous différentes formes et on peut
parfaitement réjouissant ah mais non
c'est pas du tout réjouissant je suis je
suis c'est introduire cette introduire
un conflit chronique en Europe Maurice
gourdon-montagne sur cette question on a
très peu de temps il y a d'autres
conflits chroniques regardez la Corée et
partager en deux ce qui n'est absolument
pas souhaitable pour l'Ukraine il y a un
vrai sujet qui est l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine son
indépendance et sa souveraineté le
terrain militaire en décidera c'est pour
ça que le rapport de force avec le
soutien que nous donnerons à l'Ukraine
doit permettre à l'Ukraine de s'en
sortir le mieux possible le jour où il y
aura des négociations nous ne pouvons
pas imaginer que l'Ukraine perde sa
souveraineté ça c'est certain c'est le
point centrace permet de faire le loup
sur ce point à mes yeux malheureusement
dans la suite de ce que dit l'amiral
tout à l'heure mais différemment je
crains malheureusement que cette guerre
ne signe la fin du rêve français de
défense européenne ce qui s'est passé au
moment du Conseil des ministres en
coallemand et tout à fait révélateur de
ça on était au milieu de l'affaire des
chars léopard les chars léopard n'ont
pas été décidés par Macron et scholls
ils ont été décidés trois jours plus
tard par byden et Schulz après le sommet
franco-allemand donc clairement c'est
les Américains qui ont ouvert pour les
Allemands une ombrelle qui s'appelait
les chars Abrams qui a permis à la
livraison de léopards mais ça c'est pas
fait en franco-allemand et de ce point
de vue là on voit bien que pour les
Allemands le
chef d'orchestre de cette guerre et pas
à Paris mais à Washington alors
maintenant sur comment termine cette
guerre
des décisions militaires ont été prises
tout le mois de janvier
d'intensifier de donner à l'Ukraine je
cite les termes du Pentagone de mémoire
de donner aux Ukrainiens tous les moyens
nécessaires pour reprendre la dynamique
qui est aujourd'hui bloqué
d'un champ de bataille qui est bloqué
sur 1000 km donné aux Ukrainiens tous
les moyens pour percer la défense russe
et récupérer la totalité de leur
territoire donc il y a une sorte de
search on met des armes lourdes on met
des véhicules blindés on met des
positions donnez votre position parce
que l'émission se termine ma position
est simple je souhaite qu'il se trompe
pas bien je souhaite que cette offensive
ne conduise pas à un engrenage qui
serait hors contrôle de la part de ceux
qui prennent aujourd'hui les décisions
on vous a écouté alors cette émission se
termine en aura l'occasion de revenir
vous voyez qu'à partir du
franco-allemand on arrive à la question
européenne en quoi cette
cet axe franco-allemand demeure centrale
elle me met aujourd'hui il est
internationalisé avec ce qui se passe et
notamment avec cette guerre en Ukraine
alors je voudrais avant terminer citer
une brève bibliographie alors il y a
quelques ouvrages dont je voudrais
parler il y a un ouvrage d'Hélène
milliard de la croix et Andreas Virgin
c'est très intéressant ces deux
chercheurs français et allemands ennemis
héréditaire avec un point
d'interrogation un dialogue
franco-allemand c'est très intéressant
de voir dans les nuances comment les
deux pays peuvent se situer sur l'état
du monde cette même relation
franco-allemande depuis 45 a été
informatisé ça a donné lieu à un
document du Collège des Bernardins c'est
publié chez Lethielleux là aussi on a
une vue non pas synthétique mais à la
fois singulière et globale de cette
relation franco-allemande alors Maurice
Gourdeau montagne vous avez publié des
autres ne pensent pas comme nous c'est
typiquement
j'allais dire pardonnez-moi une
expression de diplomate oui bien
nécessaire parce que on a tendance à se
projeter ce que nous sommes sur les
autres et ils ne sont pas comme nous ils
ne sont pas Pierre Lellouche alors vous
une guerre sans fin c'était bien avant
l'Ukraine mais vous pensiez déjà
l'Ukraine peut-être disons que moi je me
suis occupé de l'Ukraine depuis 30 ans
de façon très assidue
ce qui m'amuse aujourd'hui c'est de voir
combien il y a de spécialistes d'Ukraine
qui ont jamais mis les pieds quoi moi je
l'Ukraine a été un grand blanc dans
l'histoire de l'Europe toutes ces 30
dernières années ce qui montre comme
quoi l'Ukraine est un pays important
aujourd'hui
et ben écoutez il me restera il me reste
à vous remercier merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à
l'équipe de LCP d'être là avec nous pour
l'enregistrer et avant de nous quitter
je vous laisse avec cette citation de
Jean-Pierre jouillet les relations entre
la France et l'Allemagne et entre leurs
dirigeants n'ont jamais été simple dans
le cadre de l'Union européenne qui est
profond
[Musique]